well fourth of july weekend is here and
with all the fun comes the caution of
being safe and that starts right outside
your home mary jane belliesa joins us in
the newsroom now mary jane so you spoke
with some experts about some safety
advice if you're planning on lighting up
fireworks right outside the front door
huh
oh absolutely sherry i mean tree service
companies tell me this is a busy time of
year for them and combined with dead
vegetation and dry climate it's all
perfect conditions for dry leaves to
catch on fire first choice tree service
and property management company north
american commercial say
only use fireworks outdoors when
shooting them off stay away from homes
dry grass and trees and check the
weather for the day as winds can impact
smoke always have a hose or a bucket of
water on hand to help control a small
fire if it starts
if we
can recommend
four to five days of additional watering
prior to that way
no bushes are dry they've got the most
amount of water in the can and in the
event a firework does touch a plant or a
bush or a tree a palm tree you know
hopefully it doesn't catch fires because
we have thousands hundreds of thousands
of palms in this valley and it takes
time to get them done and completed so
try to get them done early in the season
more or less like may through the end of
june so you can protect your properties
experts advise you to keep palm leaves
at a nine to three cut just like on the
hands of a standard clock and if you can
take time now to keep your trees trimmed
and maintained ahead of the fourth of
july holiday and of course the best way
to ensure your safety is to avoid
setting off fireworks at your home and
instead opt for a professional show all
good advice there live in the newsroom
mayor dean balleza live local now